GOOD EVENING, WELCOME TO
WASHINGTON, I MIKE AND
WASHINGTON, I MIKE MND
WASHINGTON, I MIKE MANUAL AND IN
FOR BRET BAIER.
THIS WEEK, AFTER SUPPORTING
THROUGH THE WAR CRIMES TRIAL
THEY ACQUITTED HIM OF MURDERING
THE CAPTURE IN THE ISLAMIC STATE
FIGHTER BUT CAN FIT INTO HIM OF
WITH THE DETAINEES CROPS
COURTS.
TODAY "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
RELEASED A VIDEO OF GALLAGHER'S
FELLOW NAVY SEALs GOING IN
EVIL, TOXIC, AND SOMEONE WHO'S
WILLING TO KILL ANYBODY THAT WAS
MOVING.
AT THE PENTAGON, LOOKING AT THE
RARE BREAK IN THE MILITARY CODE
OF SILENCE.
>> WAS PERFECTLY OKAY WITH
KILLING ANYBODY.
>> THIS IS HOW IT NAVY SEALs
AND EDDIE GALLAGHER DECIDE TO
THE VETERAN OF AIDS MASS THE
POINT IS ACCUSED THE ISIS
FIGHTER
>> HE GOT CRAZIER AND CRAZIER.
HE IS TOXIC.
>> HE GAVE THEM THE NICKNAME
"BLADE" THEY HAVE NOT
AUTHENTICATED THE VIDEO.
THE VIDEO APPEARS TO BE IN THE
REPORT IN QUESTION AND USING THE
DECEASED BODY OF THE ISIS
FIGHTER HE WAS ACCUSED OF
KILLING AND SOME OF THE FELLOW
SEALS.
>> YOU STOPPED AT ONE TIME OR A
COUPLE TIMES AND PROBABLY TWO OR
THREE TIMES.
YOU STABBED JUST RIGHT HERE.
NO WAY THERE IS ANYTHING BUT AN
ATTACK TO KILL THIS PERSON.
>> WE DID YOU DO NEXT?
>> I STAYED AT THE SAME UNTIL
THE ISIS FIGHTER.
OF >> DURING HIS TRIAL, THE
NAVY'S SEAL CORY CHANGED HIS
STORY ON THE WITNESS STAND.
OF >> YOU DID NOT SAY HE
SUFFOCATED DID YOU?
DO YOU SUFFOCATE?
>> YES.
HOW?
>> I HELD MY THUMB OVER HIS TUBE
UNTIL HE STOPPED BREATHING.
>> HE RESPONDED THROUGH HIS
LAWYER SAYING "MY FIRST REACTION
TO SEEING THE VIDEO WAS
SURPRISED AND DISCUSSED THAT
THEY WOULD MAKE UP BLATANT LIES
ABOUT ME BUT I QUICKLY REALIZED
THEY WERE SCARED THE TRUTH WOULD
COME OUT AND HOW COWARDLY THEY
ACTED ON DEPLOYMENT.
IF" HE WAS FOUND NOT GUILTY OF
KILLING LAST SUMMER BUT WAS
FOUND KILLING OF A LEISURE
CHARGE POSING FOR THE PHOTO AND
WAS CONVICTED AND DEMOTED TO
PRESIDENT TRUMP INTERVIEWED
PRESIDENT TRUMP INTERVEEWED
PRESIDENT TRUMP INTERVENEED
PRESIDENT TRUMP INTERVENED IN
NOVEMBER.
>> HE WAS ONE OF THE ULTIMATE
FIGHTERS.
A TOUGH GUY.
THESE ARE NOT WEAK PEOPLE,
PERIOD OF
PERIOD >F
PERIOD >> THE PRESIDENT HAS NOT
SHIED AWAY FROM THE SUPPORT FROM
EDDIE GALLAGHER AFTER ACQUITTING
HIM.
HE WAS OFFICIALS SAY THE NAVY
SEALs TOP ADMIRAL COLIN GREENE
WANTED TO CONVENE A BOARD TO SEE
IF HIS COVETED TRIDENT PIN, THE
MARK OF HIS NAVY SEAL SHOULD BE
STRIPPED.
>> THIS IS ABOUT EGO AND
RETALIATION, IT HAS NOTHING TO
DO WITH GOOD ORDER AND
DISCIPLINE.
>> LATE SEAL CORY SCOTT NEVER
CHANGE THE STORY AND SCOTT SAID
ALL ALONG HOW THE ISIS FIGHTER
DIED BUT HE NEVER SAID HOW UNTIL
THE TRIAL.